hagamos un ejemplo en el que calculemos
la suma de series geométricas finitas y
sólo como un recordatorio en un vídeo
anterior redujimos la fórmula en la que
la suma de los n términos es igual a
nuestro primer término por 1 - r elevada
a la potencia n y todo eso entre 1 - ser
entonces apliquemos eso a esta serie
geométrica finita que tenemos aquí cuál
es nuestro primer término y cuál sería r
y cuáles sen bueno algunos de ustedes
tal vez ya lo están visualizando pero
para que se entienda mejor vamos a
expandir esto un poco esto es igual a 2
por 3 a la 0 así que sólo nos queda dos
más dos por tres a la primera potencia
más dos por tres al cuadrado más
por 3 al cubo y así consecutivamente
hasta 2 por 3 a la 99 entonces cuál es
nuestro primer término cuál es nuestra a
bueno en este caso a es igual a todos lo
tenemos en todos estos términos entonces
a es igual a 2 y cuál sería r bueno en
cada término sucesivo conforme cada
incrementa de uno en uno estamos
multiplicando por tres entonces 3 es
nuestra r este es nuestra r y este
término es a y finalmente cuál es
nuestra n bueno tal vez me digan cómo
vamos hasta el 99 tal vez en es igual a
99 pero si se dan cuenta
empezamos con acá igual a 0 por lo que
en total tenemos 100 términos
términos miren cuando k es igual a 0
ese es nuestro primer término y cuando
acá es igual a 1 ese es nuestro segundo
término cuando acá es igual a 2
ese es nuestro tercer término y cuando
acá es igual a 3 ese es nuestro cuarto
término entonces cuando acá es igual a
99 este es nuestro término 100 así que
en realidad queremos encontrar ese
subíndice 100 vamos a escribir ese
subíndice 100 y para esta serie
geométrica es igual a dos por uno menos
tres a la 100 y todo eso entre 1 - 3
y podemos simplificar esto
aritméticamente aquí abajo nos queda
menos 2 entonces 2 entre menos 2 que es
igual a menos 1 y menos por uno menos 3
a la 100 es igual a esto es igual a 3 a
las 100 menos 1 ahí está